adjoint nom masculin désignant une
personne chargée d'en aider une autre
dans cet âge soit super dans une mairie
l'autre c'est le maître un adjoint et un
second dans un conseil municipal il est
membre d un deuxième un troisième c'est
le conseil municipal qui en décide du
nombre sans pouvoir dépasser 30% de son
propre effectif
un adjoint c'est un peu le chouchou de
la maîtresse autorisé à s'asseoir à côté
d'elle et la place de la chaise dépend
souvent du degré de chouchoutage
l'adjoint ne fait pas banquette pour
repère il s'occupe d'un domaine précis
comme la jeunesse ou des transports
parce qu un maire n'est pas une mère
katherine ne peut pas tout faire le
premier adjoint lui est le chouchou en
chef en charge du budget
c'est à lui qu'on a donné la boîte de
bons points et c'est lui qui les
distribuent l'anssi en charge
l'aménagement de la commune
un adjoint touche une indemnité de 251
euros dans les communes de moins de 500
m temps jusqu'à 2600 56 euros dans les
plus de deux cent mille habitants
évacués enfin la question du genre il
existe des adjoints signé les tigres du
bengale encore liberté c'est rare mais
ça existe
il arrête la nouvelle loi sur la parité
dans ce scrutin de liste il risque d'y
en avoir plus d'une d'adjoint couleurs
espèces va donc être préservée grâce à
une politique volontariste de naissance
en captivité
je regarde si votre bungalow pas des
adjointes quoique à un banal